Hi, guys, Dr. Berg here.
I want to answer the question, "How long does
it take to get into ketosis?"
That's fat-burning, right?
It's a good question.
A lot of times, people expect it to happen
in two minutes.
It's not going to happen that fast, right?
I want you to really understand you've been
living on sugar your whole life, okay?
Now, we're going to switch over to a completely
different fuel source.
Yourselves have to build new machines for
fat.
They have to build new enzymes to break down
a completely different source of fuel.
That takes some time.
Now, if you're really healthy, it could happen
in maybe a week.
On average, it's going to be about a month
to six weeks of completely switching up, so
your body is going to change.
You're going to feel different.
The question is, "How do you know when it's
starting to work?"
Okay?
First of all, when you are satisfied after
you eat, you can go long periods of time without
eating and not being hungry.
You don't have sugar craze anymore.
Your brain is more cognitive.
You have more focus, less brain fog.
It's basically better blood sugars.
You're remembering sharper, less urinating
through the night.
Those are all factors to look for, but in
the process, you might have any one of these
symptoms right here.
Those are good things because your body is
just making the adjustment and you've got
to do it.
You can't make the keto adaptation halfway.
You can't do a diet with some sugar everyday
and expect it to adapt.
You got to bring that sugar down to zero to
really make this work.
It's like all or nothing, because in the presence
of sugar, your body will always burn that,
it will not go after the fat.
We're training your body to adapt to fat-burning.
Once you get there, you will never go back
because you're going to feel so much better
and, of course, you're going to lose a lot
of weight.
Here are some things that you can do.
Fatigue, if you have fatigue, all that means
is you're deficient in a certain B vitamin,
B5, pantothenic acid.
It's really easy.
Just go ahead and start taking some and your
energy will come up.
Why?
because B5 is like a helper for these fat-burning
enzymes to work.
If you don't have enough B5 because you're
stressed, you're going to get tired, so you
have to feed it what it needs.
Start getting cramps in the muscle, that means
your deficient in potassium.
If you're following my eating plan, you're
on about 7 to 10 cups of vegetable per day.
You're not going to have a problem with that,
but you cannot do a ketose diet correctly
if you're not consuming vegetables.
It's not in sufficient quantity because potassium
is needed not just to flesh out all this fat
from the liver, but to help you with the nervous
system and the muscles.
That's an electrolyte, because with ketosis,
you're going to dump a lot of fluid weight,
so you need to retain some of these electrolytes.
Also salt, that's another one.
If you get muscle weakness, you need some
salt.
Bloating, bile salts, purified bile salts,
that's my gallbladder formula.
Here's a mistake that people make.
They start the ketosis, but they go too heavy
on the fats too fast and they bloat up the
gallbladder and it causes right shoulder pain.
You just can't handle the fats.
You want to start small with the fats and
gradually increase it so you don't feel too
heavy in your digestive system.
Sleep issues, that's a calcium, magnesium
issue if you're going through this.
If you're not sleeping, you're sleeping is
worse, add some calcium, magnesium, boom,
you're going to sleep.
I just wanted to explain that give it some
time, be patient, it's going to work, it always
does, but just increase your expectation of
the time it's going to take and don't think
it's going to take a day or two and then,
all of a sudden, it didn't work so you quit.
I'll see you in the next video.
Hey, guys, thank you so much for watching.
I really appreciate it.
Please click the share button below and I
will see you in the next video.